bonsoir marc-antoine bon sens d'être là
marc-antoine le bret alors marc antoine
je dois retrouver ma fiche et on s'est
retrouvé avec autant de fiches vous avez
vous pas marc-antoine bonjour bonjour
bonjour il fallait une fiche pour ça
non
oloron fema se recouvrent à rien nation
vous êtes sûrs d'éviter cette touche pas
à mon pote il va refaire sur l'entrée
salut marc-antoine merci d'être venu et
on accueille tout de suite la tribu
tateurs marc antoine desnoyers m'affiche
bonjour attendant marc antoine
bonsoir et à monsieur planté g 2 mois
dire la messe marc-antoine trop fort on
s'en doute bien sûr j'ai rien à dire
mais non pas parti mais bien sûr vous
adore touche pas à mon poste toujours
chéri à léona que dos et c'est mon envie
de passer devant la caméra d'or
on connaît un succès fou toi ici aller
marc-antoine le bret pour prendre des
nouvelles de pierre aux leçons le jour
on cherche une émission de télé
présentée dans un fort par olivier minne
anadys chez vous la sellette ce jeu là
aiment ce jeu on y va tant que je mets
en scène une personne de petite taille
qui est bon comédien
je ne suis donc pas joséphine ange
gardien dont montre un très vieil homme
dont on ne comprend pas ce qu'il dit
mais je ne suis pas vivement dimanche
je suis célèbre pour ma boule mais je ne
suis pas lance armstrong je suis je suis
je reste concentré jean-luc vous gagnez
d'encyclopédie les arts de lille est
aussitôt midi des ménagères de moins de
50 ans qui fantasme sur le olivier vide
c'est-à-dire and annuaires en il pleut
défi je le faisais et vend son cas c'est
la langue arabe bien ça va bien un
problème ou quoi cyril un ton émission
d'aujourd'hui elle est vraiment
incroyable parce que tu es un invité
beau athlétique et super charismatique
ouais c'est beaucoup de chance que je
sois d'armor dans votre émission
d'ailleurs je vais en profiter pour
saluer quelqu'un que j'admire tu me
fascine la personne qui compte le plus
pour moi
coucou mon amour voilà maintenant bah je
vais rentrer chez moi parce que j'ai
enregistrée l'émission je vais me
regarder en train de me saluer
deux collègues des deux collègues
d'olivier puisqu'on va parler de nelson
monfort et philippe candeloro ou savait
que nous apprécions particulièrement
votre émission où cohabitent élégance et
l'énergie créative naturellement sa
place n'est ce pas mon cher fait peu
candeloro a eu raison il sonne aussi je
trouve naturellement ma place
c'est dans les audi gossio l'a compris
nelson soeur sur twitter philip jeu je
ne te laisse aucunement a souligné
j'attribue des uns ou des autres jeunes
y saluer bien plutôt les qualités de
l'ensemble des participants attendent
elson mendy dubosc et benhaim g déglingo
6ème verdez mer ou carrière tu l'emmènes
perruque il est allongé déglingo 6 1
on a des nouvelles de julien courbet
salut à tous et julien courbet eurois de
lorna que la tenait là des prochaines
cyril quand je serai parmi vous je
continuerai dénonce les arnaques
d'ailleurs je vais commencer tout de
suite j'ai ici une veste la veste qui
appartient à thierry moreau nous
d'autres thierry thierry moreau c'est
bien votre vaste
j'adhère content petit robot allons
regarder tout de suite et oui si tu dors
d'un sens bien tout ça mais je demande
une confiserie cela d'une arnaque
oui voici maintenant le blouson le
blouson bien sûr que porte jean michel
bras voilà je me souviens c'est bien
votre besoin
oui mais on attend tout de suite
vérifions tout de suite bon visiblement
jean michel maire nous allons plus jeune
vient valider sa gamme être fellonneau à
la semaine prochaine de nouvelles armes
oh